bonsoir andré bercoff merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france pourquoi
ce message tous les journalistes pensent
pareil bonsoir non tous les journalistes
heureusement pas savez je déteste
généralisation j'ai bien dit une partie
des journalistes
une bonne partie peut-être parce qu il y
a deux problèmes et on le voit très bien
vous avez suivi la polémique sûrement
dans les conseillers de l'elysée qui a
dit il faut que certains citoyens s
politiques ou journalistes soient
comptés dans le temps parole de la
campagne ce qui est déjà assez
formidable c'est à dire qu'est ce qui se
passe il y a eu une espèce de de jeu de
dominos ou certains politiques et
beaucoup deviennent les commentateurs de
l'eau propre inaction alors qu'eux ils
sont là pour travailler et faire
et puis certains journalistes si vous
voulez pour des raisons à la fois
économiques et autres dans l'industrie
le commis du journalisme sont
malheureusement et ce n'est pas toujours
leur faute et c'est souvent pas de leur
faute
obligé de faire oublier ou amenés à
faire du commentaire et de la paraphrase
alors que l'alpha et l'oméga du
journalisme c'est quand même l'enquète
c'est quand même le terrain alors c'est
très bien d'avoir des historia liste
mais le journalisme c'est allez voir
c'est d'avoir question est où est de
voir la vérité est que malheureusement
l'économie du journalisme et des médias
je ne dis pas leur localité il ya
beaucoup de gens qui font très bien leur
boulot mais il y à aussi qu'une espèce
de mimétisme total qui consiste à
effectivement au lieu d'aller faire
l'enquète parce que ça demande du temps
ça demande des moyens et bien de se
copier la l'autre au moins d'avoir une
espèce de doxa et la seconde la soul
second problème c'est justement cette
doxa cette espèce de fait pas pensée
unique
mais enfin on a un peu assez retrouve
dans certaines écoles de journalisme et
autres le même point de vue là la même
si vous le le le
même considération certain nombre de
réalités au préfère sa vision
idéologique ou sa vision militante à la
réalité et le réel il frappe à la porte
et je vais vous dire que vous appelez un
entre soi parmi donc une grande partie
du monde journalistique mais à quel cas
précis est ce que vous pensez qu'elle
médias quelle émission pas les nôtres 1
j'espère un ba écoute et non non et je
vais vous dire je pense à quelque chose
de très précis je pense par exemple à
certaines émissions du service public
france à terme france info pour le
palais nommé où il y a des gens qui font
encore une fois du bon boulot je déteste
les généralisations je les dis mais où
il y a effectivement le certaine doxa je
lirai pour être précis vail 5 millions
de personnes payent la redevance
télévision et bien sûr ses 25 millions
de ps2 foyer pardon eh bien les français
se partagent entre droite gauche centre
et caetera et j'aimerais voir plus de
diversité dans l'animation des émissions
parce que quand on dit qu'on l'a des
invités de partout très bien mais le
parti pris est souvent un parti-pris
unique et une géométrie et elle lit
l'indignation à géométrie variable
quand ça arrive c'est à dire quel côté
parce qu'on le sait le journaliste
pardonnez moi de vous couper quand vous
dites une pensée unique ça veut dire
quoi parce qu'on sait que tous les tous
les médias tous les journaux en ont
une sensibilité à l'exemple figaro plus
adroite libération plus à gauche
l'humanité très à gauche valeurs
actuelles très à droite la presse
française trop selon vous d'un côté vous
dites une pensée unique donc de quel
côté si oui lequel je prends un exemple
selon eux génie bastié du figaro et de
seignosse et je suis je lis un phénomène
sur un petit truc qui va apparaître
elle a dit il ya un phénomène
d'intolérance à l'opinion qui est plus
prégnant à gauche est ce que c'est votre
avis écoutez c'est extrêmement clair que
dans un certain nombre de journaux et et
2 et 2 et de médias l'allèle le
balancier poche à gauche et encore une
gauche extrêmement précises très daube
c'est très formaté et c est moi je ne
demande pas que le balancier passe à
droite
je demande simplement qu'il y ait
véritablement la diversité il est très
amusant de voir que les gens qui prône
la diversité
il promet différence qui prône un
certain nombre de valeurs et bien car il
s'agit d'avoir quelqu'un qui ne pense
pas comme eux eh bien ça leur plaît pas
du tout et on le voit et le ça se fait
comment par des omissions par des gens
qui ne passent jamais dans telle ou
telle émission par des gens je ne dirais
pas qu'il ya des listes noires ça c'est
faux on me l'a dit mais j'y crois pas en
revanche il y a des préférences
or qu'est-ce que c'est que l'opinion
c'est la plus important c'est d'avoir
des gens de tous bords et le débat c'est
ça le débat c'est la liberté
d'expression voyez quand je vois une
chaîne vous parler de ses news
quand je vois que des gens qui lisent à
écouter et même si new c'est pas
possible quand je vois que des
journalistes disent d'autres
journalistes
mais comment vous tolérez que tel ou tel
ou tel qu'ils sont des politiques qui
sont penchés qui penche à gauche ou à
droite
eh bien cela ne devrait pas passer c'est
quand même hallucinant
la liberté ne se divise pas la liberté
elle n'est pas de droite ou de gauche
elle est et je crois que c'est très
important de faire attention à cela
si l'on glisse rapidement alors
justement quelle solution est ce que
vous préconisez pour éviter ce
glissement éviter cet entre soi et bien
écoutez c'est extrêmement simple
c'est au lieu de le penser que par
exemple comme certaines patronne de
télévision en disant oui il
à trop de mal blanc ou bâle on sens m à
l es outre de ceux ci outre de cela fait
la vraie diversité
la vraie diversité c'est celle encore
une fois des opinions et c est que les
gens les téléspectateurs que l'électeur
fassent leur choix et c'est là qui est
important ensuite autre chose très
important faut quand même savoir où vous
demandez aux français par exemple de
payer des impôts et des redevances à ce
moment là il faut la vraie diversité et
que c'est le service public représente
la vraie université de des français
sinon et bien on supprime les
subventions et que chaque journal chaque
radio shack télévision gagne des
lecteurs et de la publicité faut savoir
ce qu'on veut on peut pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
je dis simplement vivre la diversité la
vraie diversité et pas celle qui
consiste à faire du genre ou des
minorités ou sfr etc
tout le monde doit parler mais tout le
monde doit parler dans la mesure où les
lecteurs les téléspectateurs ne sont pas
et on le sait très bien
d'une seule sensibilité et pourquoi vous
avez aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens qui à
bord donne effectivement un certain
nombre de médias pour faire eux mêmes
leurs propres cartes et ils sont plus du
tout au menu parce que justement ils en
ont marre de la pensée et a asséné
formaté dirigé andré bercoff que la
france s'apprête à se doter d'une agence
nationale de lutte contre les
manipulations de l'information en
provenance de l'étranger qui vise le
site à déstabiliser l'état bonne ou
mauvaise idée
si on n'est pas capable si on n'est pas
capable de contrer s'il ya manipulation
et c'est tout à fait possible qu'ils
aient manipulation de l'étranger ou de
l'intérieur eh bien on se bat contre une
manipulation par l'information et par
l'information de la vérité ce n'est pas
vous savez qui va faire le curseur
c'était comme la loi vient au 10è
attendez on va pas faire tel message tel
message
mais qui va choisir vous avez vu ce qui
s'est passé quand les gars femme twitter
et copalis décide de censurer trump
s'est pas masquer ses preuves mais enfin
de quel droit parce que c'est déjà cédé
organismes privés
il décide par exemple de priver tel ou
tel président ou telle politique advitam
eternam de twitter ni facebook
ça veut dire quoi si c'est pas de la
censure donc non on se bat à coups
d'opinion on se bat à coups
d'information on se bat à coude enquête
mais on ne se bat pas à coups de censure
ça c'est faux c'est ça le principe
fondamental
merci andré bercoff d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain éditorialiste également sur sud
radio